zach is in nashville
hey zach how are you hey dave how you
doing
better than i deserve what's up ah thank
you for taking my call
um okay my question is me and my wife we
are
both in our early 30s i'm currently 34
she's 32.
we're pretty well debt-free i guess my
question is i
owe 80 000 on my house right now i'm in
the position to pay it off
i haven't invested in anything and i'm
still learning that process
but i guess do i pay the house off now
or do i maybe start the roth iras or go
that route
i i don't know what the best answer is
that's
that's the reason for my call you said
zach that you can pay off the house so
does that mean you have i'm guessing a
lot of savings
uh yeah i've got about a hundred
thousand dollars i
and my wife both and like i said that
leave us about 20.
um i just i've been pretty focused on
paying the house off if i keep track
right now i'm
paying extra to the principal it
probably put me at about five years
i guess i would have it paid off yeah
how much do you make a year
about 62. that's great
well what i would do zach is considering
you have no other consumer debt you have
a good amount of savings
i would work to still fund some money
into retirement
i mean the earlier you can start this
the better off you're going to be
even three to four years the fact that
you guys can start in your early 30s is
going to be huge
and so i would fund about 15 of your
income into retirement
so opening up a roth ira if your work
has a 401k do that do you guys have kids
yes i've got two little girls one's
seven and one's a year and a half
okay do you have any college savings for
them at this point
i do not know i'm very new to the baby
steps and
like i said i was trying to figure out
what the best yeah
would be no you're doing great being in
the position yes absolutely well you're
yeah you're in a fantastic position on
paper for sure so yeah i would fund 15
of your income to retirement then i
would go and open up some
college funds for your girls so either
an esa or a 529 plan put some money
there
and then anything extra that you have
that you want to throw at the house i
would do that i would make sure you
still have an emergency fund on the side
of three to six months of expenses but
anything beyond that
i yeah i would look to be putting the
house down
did i hear you right that you have a
hundred thousand dollars in
savings and 80 000 pays the house off
correct yes i know that money's just
sitting there i know i'm just asking if
i understood you right and i wasn't
being sarcastic so if i understood you
right then
rachel's advice is perfect uh but i
would write a check today and pay off
your house
okay and that's kind of been my question
yeah then the other the other 20 000 the
other 20 000 moves over into your
emergency fund
and then out of your income without a
house payment
boom right now in your monthly budget
you set up a draw
going into your 401k or your roth iras
like rachel's talking about
or your company's plan or whatever or or
sit down with smartvestor pro and you
may want to sit down with them anyway
and then
have you know if you just start 100
bucks a month per kid
it would go a long way towards the
college as young as your kids are
and so um yeah i'd sit down and get at
least 100 bucks a month going per kid
and and at least 15 of your income going
to its retirement and without a house
payment or any other payments in the
world
you're gonna have plenty of wiggle room
in this budget to do that
yeah and that's that's kind of been my
question it was like because it frees me
up a lot once you pay that once i pay
the house off
i just didn't know if that was the best
move let me just tell you i've been
doing this 30 years and i've been
telling people for 30 years to pay off
their house every chance i got
i've never had anybody call me up and
was pissed because they paid off their
house
like dave that's the worst advice you
ruined my life dave
i've never heard that not one time
people get pissed at me about a lot of
stuff i get a lot of hate
but it's never been about paying off
your house so
i get i do apparently i make most people
mad about a lot of things but that one
not people don't get mad about that one
zach hold on i'm going to give you a
copy of the total money makeover
which has the baby steps outlined in it
on steroids every detail every nuance
every question answered about the baby
steps
shows you exactly what to do when to do
it how to do it
and it will verify the conversation that
you had with rachel and i
and i put you in a great position here
brother and what an amazing thing 34
yes way go man paid for house tomorrow
dang if you wanted
i mean the number of people do that
almost none
almost none and then to the point though
zach of not having the house payment you
have no other debt
when your income comes in and you're
completely debt for it you have no other
payments
that 15 is easily put away and then you
guys because
because i could i i would think living
with this 100 grand of cash over here
feels good like there's a level of
security there
and when that strips down to 20 there's
going to be like oh wow but building
that back up
without a mortgage payment is going to
happen so quickly well 20 000 is plenty
of an emergency fund with a 60 000
income no it is but i'm just saying just
the thought of oh yeah we could go buy a
car we could do other things with that
money
yeah that short-term savings is going to
happen so quickly without that mortgage
payment so that feeling of it
but listen to this this is what i think
cool 32
to 62 32 to 67 35 years
if he just invests if he never gets a
raise
now if you go 40 years at your job and
you never get a raise you're a loser
okay but if he never gets a raise
and he only invests 15 not more
just 15 percent that's gonna in good
mutual funds in
roth iras he's going to have between
five and seven million dollars
making 60 grand because he did this so
early
that's that kids on fire man that's cool
see that's what that's why we tell you
to pay off the house because it makes
you rich that's right yeah
and you be in a position to be
outrageously generous you know what you
can do with five to seven million
dollars
anything you want i mean and what if i'm
half wrong
he's still okay i mean still okay that's
unbelievable
so this is why nobody gets mad at me for
telling you to pay off their house they
get mad about everything else but they
don't get mad about that